俺には大学生の頃カーン中年間住んでいる街がある
その街の名前
静岡市
[音楽]
うっ
あおはようございます
今日は
すんな静岡市の肇社長がおすすめする素敵なスポットを紹介していきたいとおもいます
ぜひ参考にしてみてはいかがでしょうかいやー
天気だなぁ院展に出てみればわかりますいればわかります
まずはこちらです大
ここが東増帯域前の原っぱでいい
ここが私はよく長い便短編のかなすごいクソ
いろんな物を置いてあるんですけどあー本当に何もないめっちゃしゃべりあんめちぇ
しゃべリア
はいこちらからこちらが東静岡駅前の原っぱでございます
平日は人が少なくて
いやー穴場スポットでございますこいつも撮影で
結構使うんですよね広い
ここで
スポーツとかの動きがある動画たからここで
よくとっても金かおしゃれなかったオシャレなカットカップルがここでデートするのは
羨ましい限りですね
ちょっと刺し増加のを含め程度スポットですね
俺もここでデートしたいじんせいでしたはい続いては私肇社長もかつて動画にしたこと
のある
静岡には伝説のサウナの店があるのです
それがこちらもおおつきましたーーー
というわけでこちらが全国的にも有名なサウナサウナ式辞でございまきました
もうサウダーだったらみんな知っているぐらい次いで有名なお店いっちゃなんです
もう本当に今朝市なんですけども朝からお車がもうめっちゃ待ってて人もいっぱいなん
でちょっと園内のさっぱりだったんですけど
ああああああ
ここはぜひとも静岡に来た時は言って欲しいです
俺もめっちゃ入ってますまじでまじでくらいって欲しいまして
あのこのサウナー本当に気持ちよくて
あのマジ俺これシッターの去年とかなんですよちょっともったいないもっと早くすれば
良かった地区車
続いては駅周辺ですね静岡駅周辺のラーメン屋さんですね私の行きつけのらー皆さんを
紹介します
きょろきょろしてますねあのすごい1尾しリーダーんですね入って夕食つきました
こちら
旅行ンって書いてあるんですけど横浜家系ラーメン魂心家で御座い静岡じゃない
めっちゃってでもう今度自分に松下ラーメンはここだって言い切れるぐらい
めちゃくちゃ僕にたまたな名やですそれが java いた紀州事がで頼りすぎだろ
行くだろうけどもうぜひともここは静岡に行った時食べてほしいラーメン屋です
まあ全国的にあるんですけどね全国的に東京見た新しい
魂心家
んですが私日の静岡の更新やを進めております
赤く黒い太い心のこもった感じ
店内をとてもアットホームな雰囲気で家型の掘ってりした
美味しいラーメンが食べられるのです
ワッシャー
ハイあのいつもっていうかおすすめは熱い魂醤油ラーメン醤油ラーメンの味違っ的なん
ですけども
冬だけ寒いってだけ味噌ラーメンあるそれがぜひサティさーうーさー
味噌ラーメンを一つくださっ新しいカメラ
ねます健康に気遣ってる健康に近くに行っ
に造成
パブラスク上がるっ
健康まして侮蔑を別に健康じゃねえだろお前
こうやってしっかりとチャーシューをつくってそして
さあ集を作って
そしてメーン or 面倒市内の勝者開きましたね谷原
な目ですでございますますはい
あ noo
さあさぞきました馬そのこちらが至極のらーげん検診やの味噌ラーメンです
どっから来完璧なプロポそらー目に完璧なプロポーションとかで4アーメーン君も久々
なんじゃな
いただきます
さあ久々のラーメンということで
肇社長は今深夜のラーメンを食べて何を感じるのでしょうか
しゃべり猫千田でフーフーしてますねこちらです
さあここでしっかりと無理して食べていました扱ったレスを覚えております私でこれは
使ったんですけども
それでも味はもう絶品でございます私の静岡市で一番好きなラーメンといっても過言で
はないほど愛している
足それがこの今深夜のラーメンでございます
[音楽]
美味しそうですねまぁ
うさまでしたん
動作までさーん
さあダメ遊び終わった後肇社長はどこに向かうのでしょうか
しっかりと感染症予防でマスクをし始め社長がフラット
次に向かう場所は静岡市の
静岡市の
静岡あやっぱり俺他に店行ってた今日0
あれ俺他に高いくださった虚礼あれ
あれほど曲歌ったられやばいぜ
もう行く場所ねー
[音楽]
都合ないっ
もうナイス名
時やっぱりじゃあやばいすマジで俺
シキズト
ラーメン
パラッパ4回行かないんですよあと何もわからないとヤバイ
前レスどんな言葉からやばいもう入っ
山へもここまでの強いさんも動画
いやもう何ボウガンないもうすぐだろうとないないないですねこれこの3箇所ほぉやっ
て言ってるだけなんでいつも
あやばいもう萎えああやはもうない
もうないわこれ
警察ればいいんだ
あっはぁよ僕も本土違うけど決められたお店を超えていくことしかないんでここから
google 検索で僕が普段気づかないようなお店や魅力を発見できる
いいと思います検索してみましょう最初からそうしなさいというわけでここからは
google 系策を使っておしゃれな近くのカフェでも調べてみようと思います
あっあーっ
えっ
どしたはじめこれ愛宕山あのお洒落なカフェ
はくコーヒーるって言うんでいましたは本当に何も知らないんだなお前
こっち各は通るんだけど店の名前までわからなかったろなぁそういう意味で多いですよ
ねそれ画像もついてるんだ
もうそれは3 s おっしゃれやなぁそう静岡には各でおしゃれなお店が結構多いん
ですねあ早速行ってみるか
とにしま
笑ってね大フィギュアさあというわけで近くまで来たみたいですね
ああそこ談をお店を
発見したみたいです早速
行ってみましょうはここめっちゃ行ってみたかったんですよねこちら
ハゲ珈琲っていうコーヒーや金がおしゃれ絶対初見だと一人じゃ入れプレイ
んじゃ
すげー
戦前と申されすぎて
器具なかったで正直に言うのはそこはそこは所持に言うなあ
それを進めどれですか
はい
[音楽]
なんか苦いのはちょっと甘い甘いと好きですよ
店員さんからオススメされたのは真似もかという
をはなくて俺にも飲みやすいドリンクでした
早速頼んでみましょう
すげーちゃそれを3つ苦難で3つなんだ
多いなお前一人で3つどーむの構えまあオサレなカットに変わっちゃったしてもなぁ3
つ折り一人での文化というわけで
オサレなカフェにオサレな味わいそしてオサレな店員さん
すべてが整っている最高 no されコーヒー屋さん
各コーヒー
[音楽]
ありがとうございます可愛い
果たしその味は店すごいラップアップみたいなペルラちゃんとみたいじゃねえラン
ティアード恐れ
いつもは絶対足を運べないようなおしゃれなカフェに足を運んでみた肇社長わーなんか
飲むのがもったいない
いただきます
まずで一回も来きたことないんだよな本当に行ってみたかったんで
受けて良かったですいただきますシャア
その素敵なまずもかというドリンクはどのような味がするのでしょうか
車
ねえ
ああ
この彼は本当に良い美味しい時の顔です
本人なのでよくわかるんですねー
さあそしてこういうカフェで
カットつけてコーヒー飲んでるこういう葛藤
とってみたかったんですねー
めちゃくそおっしゃるじゃないですか
これ
やってみたかったんですねー
[音楽]
なんで3つ頼んだ
そーさまでした
さあ美味しいドリンクを集まって肇社長
次は在昌なんどお店を探しにいくのでしょうかおいしかったーーー
ちょっとここらへんもうちょっと歩いてみます
[音楽]
奪った栄孝もうめぇーんだろう
を
ああそうだ
アドベて言って実は能見性も静岡といえばここでしょ
近くのおっさあや飲み物の水着の妙のの店に初めてそうそれ
茶釜を木切ったを見せるんですね
めっちゃくちゃ評が高い消化を確認できるのも google さんのおかげ
マジ感謝マジ感謝
めっちゃくそーされさんここ10代の様子を確認できる度もとっても助かりますね
早速いくのを決めた模様ですはじめしゃちょー
ここからの距離は
あっすぐそこだやったじゃん近くにあったみたいですね
早速始め社長は腕が大ぶりのクロスステップを刻めに刻みつつ店内へ
はい
益子してから入るべし絶えない
[音楽]
しっかりと庄造こぼした以来
さあここがお茶のお店佐賀までございます
押された店内オサレな店員さん
めっちゃ目にありませ
阿波ないやつとかありままじゃあバイルの分解
[音楽]
の目ごめんさあ俺でもちょっと後で飲んでみます後々にの満開遊びのもんかい
なんでだねぇ
臣氏の国はそれがを三角的なお茶ゾーンが広がっているみたいです
お子さんのことをよく知らない俺でもわかる
ここ
ものすごい量のお茶があるんやな
茶水あるなぁ
何1000円ぐらいあるん
種類100種類んを
せっかくなんで静岡のお茶飲みたいんですけど何かおすすめあります
一つを静岡市葵区梅ケ島うわずかから入った
あとは芝だしかなやんのお茶です棒
じゃーん
佳子さまノート沸く中に代入し自然かまぁ今までの説明などと文句も言わずしっかりと
を2入れてくれる店員さん
お茶を作る伸びるなんて高校の彼女の酒井以来だな
思い出したら泣けてきたら高校の時に付き合っていた彼女が茶道部の部員で俺は文化祭
の
を
境に何か言ったかな5回6回ぐらいか良い
すべてた時があった記憶を持たせないてますよ肇社長
悲しい気持ちを思い出しているみたいですね
お茶わーお願いですねんあっ覚えでもさー
を者が
完成したみたいです
なんと透き通った緑色
いただけます車速飲んでみましょう
大
どうだったのでしょうか
おっちゃ最低だなぁは最低だよその感想は
小学生じゃねーかダメだろう
聞くに亀ですかこれ
あーないんだこれで別にいいかだった気がするけど
だからお子ちゃまですねこの男は
顔に出てるよあー変わり
出てますねこの男
お店男女へだなぁ
すいませんあの甘い甘い後
ライドにしなさいよアンタは勝手だったら全く
でもそんな気持ちもわかります初めてのお店に初めての味
ついつい自分が普段挑戦しないような市食べ物飲み物に挑戦したくなりますね
n
全チャを誓っ立っちゃって全然の技から全チャを使った建
あのお茶って苦いイメージがありますがこれは
にガイドが2月8な方でも楽しめるドリンクになっているようです
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
うまそう
さっそく飲んでみることに
お味はどうなのでしょう
[音楽]
一番良い感想ですはじめ社長が雨っていう時は幸せの絶好調
もうあなたの俺にはたまらなく美味しい雑感2階があるのがまた美味しさを引き立てて
ついつい笑っちゃう美味しさでした
茶釜ぜひ
行ってみてくださいここで雰囲気を出すために
おしゃれなカットが入りますがいいですね
おしゃれです
美味しかったなぁお茶
いっちゃ
おっチャオチャオとぞ
このったぞぞ淀ドロッドロッドロドロっだぁーっ
ドローンだドローンとを下げなかった
ドローどうしてああなってもドローン飛ばせるとかってあったっけっこうこれ編
全然わかんないなぁ
近くドローン飛ばせればないかはい
そんな時も google 検索を使えばすぐ見つかりますね
の
ドローさあ
近くにドローンを飛ばせるところはありますねこれ
あったねーすげあるそうなんです調べれば意外とあるもんなんですね
ちなみに私ドローンの免許を持っておりますのである程度操作技術はあるのですはじめ
ちゃうねぇえええ
360度相談です google さあこれすごいんですよ
もう360度カメラで店内の様子がすべてわかる
これはもう行くしかねえ取るドローンとボスてっ最高の虚実数選挙
飲んで飲んで最後は鳥羽する最後に来た場所はドローンパーク静岡です
桜ビルからにドローンが飛ばせそうな倉庫のような佇まい
店内は360度カメラで確認済み
怖くないもん
ああ
大
10代は広く初心者にでもわかりやすく
ドローンで遊べるみたいですドローンレースに使われるような障害物がたくさん
オンしてやりましたまあまあ俺の技術うたら余裕なんだけどねぇまぁ全然
早速ドローンローズ号さあ始め社長
ドローンの便器を持っていますシカト
をしかとその上に俺のドローン操作技術を刮目せよ
さあさっそく賞与えっよこれは全然甘くて来てね全然うまくできてねーじゃねーか
そうですドローンわーそうなんですねちょっと
ないとすぐ左になっちゃうもうぶつかりまくりぶつければクリでもう本当に免許持っ
てんのみたいな感じですけど徐々に慣れてきた様子ですね
下草も分からないことがあれば優しく丁寧に教えてくださり
ドローンを使ったことがない操作したことがない方でも簡単にドローンで遊ぶことが
できる
素敵なお店でした
[音楽]
気づけば肇社長もう夢中ですね
お高いですかねぇ h きっとリアン
ねこれほんと楽しかったですオーケーで酒ですあのドローン
夢中になったらほんとはまっちゃいますこんなもんですかね
ここだここですねこれはばっか置くブルー
昭和異物のやつですね左右上下の位置がとても重要になる
難しい障害物です愛機だっぽいですねさあそれはそして
ドローンの目線ですねドローンは何を感じて何を見ているのでしょうか
おっとそこに見えるのは初めて
超ですねどんどん近づいて笑っていますねはい
ん
近所にはスレないよ店知らない発見が
7ばたくさんありますそれはまるで宇宙の女王
中年間この末に住んでいる僕ですら気づかないお店や気付かない発見が今回たくさん
ありました
[音楽]
そんな無限の可能性を秘めているこの静岡市が僕は
大好きですね
ちょうどほどよく都会です
自然も多いし海も川も山も使
人も優しい最近は仕事でなかなか酒造がにいる時間は減ったけどそれでも俺はこの街が
好きです
[音楽]
はいというわけでですね近所のことをたくさん知ってるなーと思ってるんですけど全然
北知れませんでした
あの今日検索してみたらまだまだ僕ん家の周り
禁ずには知らないお店がたくさんありましたいやぁ楽しかったなやたがとくねこれあれ
あっでこういう楽しむことが近所のお店を盛り上げでそしてを
防衛することにつながると思うので皆さんの近所にも素敵なお店きっとあると思うので
是非
google で検索して発見してみてくださいじゃーん
台東区で飛ぶねー特 a 貧者
eha
4日
駄文
んをっ
ん